everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage I am your host H Foley
this is the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians or classy
individuals or if their absolute garbage
I'm coming at you from beautiful Astoria
Queens where the bodies are stacking hi
my friends my co-host coming at you from
an undisclosed location somewhere in
southern New Jersey our good pal Kippy
Kevin James Ryan everybody hey gang
happy to be here another day down in the
bunker and it's not I'm not coming back
for a long [ __ ] time [ __ ] going down
with the ship buddy I'm kind of first
lifeboat out of town thank you so much
for listening everybody please make sure
you rate review subscribe on iTunes on
YouTube full video available on YouTube
we appreciate all the support so far
guys absolutely a very special guest
today we're so happy to have him here
ladies and gentlemen let me read you off
this [ __ ] rap sheet on this right
here we got the Joe Rogan experience we
got the Late Show with James Corden this
week at the Comedy Cellar The Tonight
Show with Jimmy Fallon stand-ups on
Netflix which he has an executive
producer credit for which aren't even a
high do you [ __ ] get that he got
Conan you got a Comedy Central half-hour
Last Comic Standing The Late Show with
David Letterman and he's got a brand new
podcast out right now called mindful
metal jacket and one of the co-hosts of
Tuesdays with stories the [ __ ] pride
of Massachusetts ladies and gentlemen
joltin Joe listen everybody the only
thing he's good at are you really you
guys are holding down over there yeah we
got a pretty nice lady I don't want to
go be with my parents yes that was the
big thing - I'd like to get out of this
- my parents live in the suburbs outside
of Philly and I wouldn't mind having a
little bit of [ __ ] breathing room cuz
over here it's like everybody's on top
of each other there but yeah I don't
want to go home and [ __ ] kill my
parents because I mean we put gloves and
masks on but we're still in the grocery
store we're still you know we got to go
to [ __ ] CVS and get [ __ ] yeah I put a
mask this
so embarrassing like I have such a weak
jawline if I talk my mask comes off
there's no action to hold it in place I
want to kill myself my glasses keep
fogging up when I have it on and I mean
I can store like a psycho
I saw yeah that's that's a tough look
when you're like look wandering around
the key foods and you can you know some
people get it and then some people you
walk into a place and you're like do we
wanted to get a bottle of wine and we
took a walk over towards Ditmars so we
went to another wine store that we don't
normally go to there's literally ten
people in there no masks on just hang in
the [ __ ] out talking to each other I'm
like what are you out of your [ __ ]
mind Pierre little cooped up in a
one-bedroom in Queens let's go follow
the rules I want to get this [ __ ] back
up and running I hate it and I don't
understand but I'm like I don't
understand how it's gonna like if we
went through 15 cases to 300,000 cases
in two months how are we gonna go how
would that not happen again
yeah yeah I don't understand it it's
crazy I was I went to a [ __ ] Walmart
and after being in there for seven
minutes I'm like we the human population
does not stand a [ __ ] chance against
this thing people were so close to me
even for non quarantine rules I'm like
dude what - get the [ __ ] out of my
personal space right now
no they're masse off and digging in
their mouths and then like going back to
shop and that's terrible what are your
projections Joe what do you think things
will be back to normal I don't know
yesterday I'm like debbie downer here
like I read a thing that said there's
gonna be no live events until September
2021
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah I think and the
doctor felt she said maybe in November
ish but I feel like they're all just
trying to like behind the scenes are
like yeah I know China has not given up
the real numbers I'll tell you that
right now they're [ __ ] they're
playing like the Astros they're they got
somebody cooking the books somebody is
[ __ ] those things are yeah no way
those numbers are real yes I don't know
I guess like I've heard a couple things
about like this finger prick business
that takes four minutes and then they're
like okay you're clear so maybe we want
to get our fingers prick before we go to
a baseball game I don't know
it's [ __ ] we're trying to try to test
320 some million people is gonna be
impossible and no one's gonna [ __ ]
trust it no I think you know this is
what I'm doing I'm just like there's
that old saying do business as though
the person's trying to screw you because
most likely they are that's how I feel
I'm like I will be here until 2022 and
I'll just be pleasantly surprised if not
sure man expect thanks you know expect a
bet expect the worst
that's old-school garbage mentality I
[ __ ] love that that's like something
your uncle told you one night when he
had to [ __ ] a couple it
Cuddy Starks in them yeah that's that's
the best I want to get in that a little
bit well where exactly did you grow up
in Massachusetts I grew up in Whitman
Massachusetts which is the birthplace of
the chocolate-chip cookie man after
Foley's heart right there the home of
the Ritz pick up girls at bars with that
[Laughter]
but yes like so sure about 35 minutes
south of Boston it's right next to
Brockton Massachusetts which was the
home of Rocky Marciano and bright Marvin
Hagler and you grew up so it's kind of a
suburban area yeah very suburban yeah
grew up with your painting your brothers
and sisters growing up I got one older
sister she's four years old women All
Right see you guys intertwined a little
bit some like she was like 10 years old
or anything like that
no she what she I was in eighth grade
when she was a senior so we were never
in high school together but we hung out
in the neighborhood a la did you both go
to the same school all the same tools
but we were only in the same school I
think when she was in fifth grade and
that was in elementary school we were
never in middle school or high school to
miss a school I always thought it was
garbage though and Kevin had this
growing up is when one sibling goes to
one high school and then the other one
goes to another one for some reason I
had a brother go to private school and I
did not get the nod to go to go to the
expensive private school Oh was he all
the new Utley
they were like oh we made a mistake we
can't afford that yeah kinda was but I
mean he wasn't that much older and we
would have it was same thing we would
have overlapped like one year I wasn't
but that's also the thing I also have a
brother I have there's a there's a 21
year age gap between my youngest
half-brother and my oldest sibling oh
yeah that like that's that's bad
well that's my parents and I age that's
garbage Kippy what the family drink
that's garbage
either way though one year old you're
sure the worst thing so my dad my
parents are divorced my dad got
remarried and he had at one point he had
a he had a son when my sister who's the
oldest was 16 so it was a 16 year age
gap more like jesus [ __ ] christ this
is embarrassing but all right having to
explain this story is like it's like
let's keep our head down let's not you
know let's not tell the neighbors and
we'll get through this and then five
years later they had another kid I'm
you're like Joe did you onething wake
out of your parents still together and
all that my parents are still to go I
believe that my parents have only ever
been with each other they were like high
school and then my they had my sister my
dad was 18 and my mother was 17 I think
what for no no I'm sorry my mother was
19 my dad was 20 my mother was 19 dude
back then that was the norm my high
school girlfriends parent my her mom had
her when she was 16
so like growing up we were almost like
peers and me like by the time we got in
high school she was only like [ __ ] 15
years older than that's like a spring
stick [ __ ] yeah this is a few things
like that my family like my mother I
have an uncle that's four years older
than me my mother that's always a dead
giveaway for sure
yeah buddy for years I've been telling
stories about my uncle Dale and I'll
tell because we were drinking but it so
would be Isaac me my uncle Dale we were
out
doubt we [ __ ] threw up all stuff
people like your uncle that's great you
know hitting the streets like a 60 year
old guy but do your folks have because
your Boston accent isn't isn't too thick
do your folks have have a thicker accent
my mother's like is very good I think my
mother is very self-conscious about
being sort of a lower middle class so
she worked on her penmanship and her
enunciation my dad has an accent yeah
much thicker and then especially when I
used to drink I would sound like a
Kennedy a little bit if I go it'll come
out a little bit when I start getting
angry but I tried to not have an accent
cause it was like spazzy it was very
silly to have an accent and then Good
Will Hunting came out I don't Sherlock I
used to say I always said bathroom and
my friends would make fun of me because
I had like a thick accent I pronounced
it bathroom the earliest bit I remember
having I was like in sixth grade and I
would say isn't it weird you take a bath
in the bathroom and they were like
bathroom what do you and somebody like
this kid that made it so cool man even
like confined were from Philly so like
it was the same we would hear that
Boston accent I'm like that's cool like
Philly's tough but I'm like Boston
that's a cool [ __ ] City on the guy's
it's not that bad but on the girl like
that one girl in the bar that hey Chucky
why don't you give it a little tug in
bet you're like oh what do you think is
trashy er the filling with a Boston
accent I I think Boston honestly it
because it just is like harsher and it's
Hacha and it [ __ ] just yeah and
Boston it's more than just an accent
it's like this weird back of the throat
thing like it's not just a way of saying
a word but it's like the voice
inflection
it's [ __ ] back here and it's just
upset I never understood where accents
came
why the [ __ ] do we all talk different I
don't know it's fascinating then like
Western Massachusetts I got a friend
from Western Mass he sounds like he's
from Chicago
he says Western Mass yeah Wow yeah fully
you kind of have that too high central
Pennsylvania your dad sounds like he was
on that like two bears
yeah my dad sounds like [ __ ] dan
Aykroyd because I was born in I was born
at Wolf's Barre Pennsylvania and then we
moved down the Philly so everybody up at
wilkes-barre Pennsylvania near Scranton
they all [ __ ] sound like you know
like you know hey how you doing there
good to see it they all have like that's
[ __ ] garbage - man that Chicago accent
I don't care how hot the chick is she
starts talking you're like yeah there's
a huge that's to me like the most common
accent because that goes from like Ohio
even into like Indiana and Michigan has
that yeah that spreads I feel like even
down like Nebraska they almost have that
it's interesting yeah sometimes the
southern accent can sound pretty classy
sometimes yeah yeah but it also I feel a
feel of southern accent depends on what
they're wearing if they're in like a
white suit with like the tie yeah if
they're dressed like a southern lawyer
for sure but it's like a hillbilly
you're like all right I'm not buying it
that's too funny all right well let's
get into some questions here as you know
Joe we're gonna ask you series a
question just answer them honestly we'll
find out if you're a classy guy or
absolute garbage what so what do you
what do you go with the over-under here
uh yeah I think this is my opinion I
think you I think you like most of us
have garbage routes you know what I mean
a lot of most like white suburban people
have garbage routes for sure you know
blue-collar working family so but I
don't think you're garbage now I don't
think so I think you're gonna you know I
think he I think you probably keep a
pretty tight ship remember you told I
feel like he thinks he's on the witness
stand right well I'm excited to find out
myself because I go back and forth
myself on
yeah all right well let's get into it
let's start off with a couple of the
basics growing up you had a front yard
and all that stuff you guys grew up in a
house house front yard back yeah I
thought about this yesterday when we
went for our walk what was your front
lawn ornament situation your front lawn
decoration like was there like a flower
bed with like a lawn jockey and like a
tire that's turned into a flower pot no
we didn't again a lot of these are
because my mother grew up with all that
like my grandmother collected [ __ ] she
was my grandmother had the wooden thing
where I made a lady looked like she was
bending over and you could see her
underwear so my mother was like throw
everything out like yeah yeah nothing
like Christmas we had very subtle lights
the bushes would have Christmas lights
and then there was like a little garden
in the front flowers my mother is very
OCD and very like we have to now this it
sounds like it puts us in the we're
classy but it's really just a huge
effort to hide behind the tracking it's
a deep garbage yeah there was very few
lon anything I would say actually zero
long other than actual flowers what
about around Christmas time did you put
like the sled and like the the plastic
sled with the lights out there anything
like that no nothing like that just just
lights just standard frame the house and
some on the bushes and the big one the
Christmas tree inside did you have
colored lights Joe we had colored lights
[Laughter]
I think they stopped making those in the
70s those things are wacky how many
houses that they [ __ ] burned down
those things did you have a garage we we
had a garage a garage there was note
when we first got the house there's just
filled with [ __ ] and the garage door was
so Jim you couldn't open it it was like
so rusted shut
but when I was around I think early on I
be first moved there like three years in
the moving that we we gutted everything
and made it a big living room oh that's
so then no is the short answer when we
first moved there
it was an open Amol garage door wait a
minute wait a minute you said you said
you made it into a living room yeah it's
like a big now it's like beautiful but
they became like a dining room thing so
it was attached to the house it was a
garage attached to that yes my garage is
my parents garage is not attached to the
house I don't think it's good I don't
have all my papers in front of me but I
don't think we were asking because the
garage fridge is a big thing that we
growing up we eat a garage fridges but
like you know that just get beer sodas
and weird meats stored in sodas ice pops
and [ __ ] like that
no one fridge okay I got another one
were you like a blockbuster family or
independent rental store Oh interesting
we became balls
we ended up being blockbuster a
blockbuster yeah but there was like
stones video for a little bit but they
always had the best name stones guy
that's great once blockbuster became a
thing we worse we were straight
blockbuster yeah you kind of had to me
you had no choice they had the monopoly
on it blockbuster was much classier than
like did you guys have West Coast video
up there too or now I don't think we had
that cuz West Coast had the [ __ ] back
room blockbuster never had the back room
no I can picture our blockbuster now all
the new releases went all the way around
the outside yeah
yes it didn't have that porn room it was
[ __ ] it was pretty classy but we did
occasionally I remember there was a time
with the liquor store movie she could
rent movies from the liquor store
because I going to the liquor store and
beyond the are you pick out a movie I
just thought of it now I'm like
and that was really where they had the
actual movie case inside the plastic
like Blockbuster had their own yeah yeah
lock what's their case this was just the
movie and a plastic thing Wow
that's why I've never heard of that but
that doesn't remind me buddy of mine
growing up his dad owns like two or
three like independent rental stores and
when they closed down when Blockbuster
moved it down he sold all the movies but
kept all of the porn from like the three
locations and kept it all in his
basement we found him when we were like
15 and it was the greatest day of my
life it was amazing he had like all of
pornhub in his basement and we were like
what's in these boxes he's like porn and
we were like all of these boxes like
yeah [ __ ] great alright so you pass
the test on the long decorations what
about a flag set up you have any flag
set up the American flag is obviously
okay but did you have like a Red Sox
flag or like a Patriots flag or the big
one is did you have a pirate flag no all
right my dad still has a pirate flag
flying in our backyard like he's [ __ ]
Jolly Rogers [ __ ] garbage he thinks
he's a pirate that's insane have you
ever have you ever used the ATM just to
check your balance interesting no I'm
like the opposite I've never checked my
bed I take money out and I say no the
risk because I don't want to look okay I
have that same anxiety I'm like I don't
want to push that off until tomorrow or
something yeah to this day like I've
done okay I have some money I still
don't look at the back because it still
[ __ ] me up I've had moments where I've
gone to the ATM and like that person
before me their receipt still in there
you know and I take a peek just a little
[ __ ] see what see what the
competition is dealing with and some
guys got like [ __ ] 25 grand just
sitting his checking account
my quant oh [ __ ] I've thought about that
now because I have like a savings
account I've thought about doing
checking the savings and then just
leaving the receipt just to be like just
to make me feel bad about myself a bomb
behind
like that leave a 20 on the machine go
ahead take care all right growing up did
your mom buy gushers no no no I feel
like that was a rich kid snack I didn't
have gosh we were a fruit roll-up family
no no off-brand fruit roll it family for
us
what about Lunchables did you get
Lunchables I don't think so I was also
like a crazy picky eater I do remember
the little plastic thing with the stick
and the cheese those things are [ __ ]
classy yeah all right
we never did Lunchables I think but
here's the thing again I have my
mother's OCD so like I had the same
lunch every day
I had like peanut butter and jelly and
one of those cheese stick things that's
not bad for a fourth grader that's clean
living you get a PB&J sandwich and a
handy snack it was pretty good then you
pull up those handi-snacks it was like
you were spreading caviar on this pill
do you get a sixth grade runt room that
whole place will stop [ __ ] check this
guy out
they were [ __ ] nice man all right to
stay on that peanut butter and jelly tip
I got one for you
did your mom ever get you the peanut
butter and jelly in the same jar no
again I mean I gotta keep coming back to
this OCD that was psychotic
the same way man that's insane to me
yeah I spread the peanut butter and then
like fully wiped down the knife before
going into the jelly like my mother aged
[ __ ] her pants if there was peanut
butter and the jelly or jelly in the
peanut butter
oh you got you can see the [ __ ] jelly
in my fridge right now it's got peanut
butter butter that's got a set of keys
in it the thought of your jelly jar [ __ ]
you it makes my skin crawl dude suck
what you do you guys refrigerate your
jelly you're supposed to refrigerate
after you open it yeah are you taping
over the bed what do you didn't I keep
it in the cabin once you put it in the
fridge that's it I'm done with it that's
how I feel about ketchup I've been
having this debate my whole life we're
always ketchup in the in the cabinet
people keep to catch up nice and warm
all right I'll give you that I like that
yeah I do the same thing with the milk I
keep the milk in the oven
my Simurgh oven and since that came up
I've talked to your wife Sarah about
just before she's a big milk drinker
have you growing up did you ever have
milk with dinner we always ask this
question I think I did I think I like at
one point thinking about this now I
could just have diarrhea right in the
bedroom sitting here but I can remember
as a kid
liking milk with macaroni and cheese it
would
[Laughter]
so you just answered another question a
common common woman here you are a craft
macaroni and cheese family yeah the blue
box box yeah classy I love that up until
recently I would eat the full box like
in my adulthood I'd make an entire box
and then eat it yeah I mean if you're
making a box area you know yeah bridge
yeah yeah but once I hit like 35 I would
do that and be like suicidal the next
day it took me three days to recover it
you can taste the box a little bit in it
that's what I love about craft Mackley
you can taste like the cardboard in the
box like in like in the aftertaste of it
it's killer as I'm talking about it I'm
like I should do I should go do that
just for old times sake cuz I miss it
fully I think you're just eating the box
to be honest what about what about your
chocolate melt growing up were you a
chocolate syrup family or were you a
powder family no we were a syrup family
good powder have you had next quick you
were [ __ ] trash I did something a
little weird that everyone thinks I'm
crazy and now I'm starting I'm finally
coming around with some work and therapy
to recognize that I was wrong but I
would put the chocolate in first because
I wanted to see how much chuckles like I
judged by like almost like forming a
whisky I was like I want two fingers of
a person for the milk on top of it and I
always did like yeah I thought that was
the right way to do it no do the milk
first yes
ah that's [ __ ] garbage now I want to
know what I'm getting not yet I want
that spoon standing straight up that's
how I always thought mine would look
like black and looking a Black Russian
yeah and you gotta go Hershey's that was
my second thing if he goes
it has to be Hershey's I feel like
that's quick that's quick was new money
[ __ ] yeah you can smell nests click on
somebody a mile away yeah that cracked
out [ __ ] rabbit jumping around no
[ __ ] thank you I still got I got a
couple more food once I guess where did
you guys do Nilla wafers growing up all
right I was we would get them every now
and then also this is a big one father
we've talked about it before did you
have you ever had the dessert known as
dirt no do you know what it is no I
don't know it's large it's it's the
trashiest thing in the world it's ice
cream pudding and they put it and then
they crumble like Oreos and stuff in it
it's made to look like dirt and they put
like gummy worms in it and a lot of
times you eat it out of like a like a
planter like a pop that you a plant in
you know look on your face no way what
if what about ambrosia never have
ambrosia no it's like mayonnaise and I
don't even know what mayonnaise and
marshmallows it's a weird combination
what was your mayo growing up and the
house was it Hellmann's or was it
Miracle Whip you know I was never many
as guy but Miracle Whip we definitely
had that in the house America whoops not
even Mayo it's referred to as salad
spread we might have had Bulls
I don't quote me on that you go on there
you [ __ ] embarrass this like where
they're going family Joey's on a radio
talk a bed what about a toaster oven do
you now or did you own growing up a
toaster oven no my grandmother had a
toaster oven so I was familiar but we
did not in my house no we had a total we
don't we don't now we're a toaster
family that's I know you do we
toast dude this blows my mind here now
toaster oven those things are trash
either a regular toaster or you [ __ ]
throw it in the oven toaster oven no
that's crazy
that you imprison those things always
had [ __ ] gunk all over I'm standing
by it it's it's not trashy
all right um did you have were you ever
have big league chew bubblegum I was not
that was my neighborhood but I never got
into it I was not a big shoe guy oh man
you felt like a [ __ ] million bucks if
you were on deck and little and Little
League and pulled out some big league -
man that was clean [ __ ] living here I
hated dinger got in my head if you
swallow gum you could die or you would
never be legit again so the idea of
having gum while playing baseball was
insane to me really psychotic
I remember swallowing gum a couple of
times and thinking I was gonna die
instantly it's such a frightening thing
once it gets in the back of your throat
you're like oh it's gonna stick I'm dead
just the idea when you're a kid as an
adult - you just get some information
and you lose the rest of the information
around it so all I knew is you can't
swallow gum and that was enough for me
to fill in the rest of life you gotta
get up you die yeah yeah yeah for sure I
only heard the first part but I think
you die if you swallow go you know what
else was big bubble tape was big back in
the day long I was rich kitchen really
yeah never got bald what the dollar 20
not in a clip that was a rich kid [ __ ] I
was never happening you couldn't you
couldn't afford that I loved the of the
CBS I remember always chew and [ __ ]
sugar-free gum because that's what my
mom got like we had a winter fresh or
something like that
we were chewy we were eating like like
old lady gum maybe I'd tried it and big
red big Reds not bad man I haven't put a
piece of big red recently we talked
about feeling like a million bucks
walking into this but big red is good
for like legitimately under 60 seconds
yeah those de Luz flavor so quick and
dries your mouth out like you like a
shot
rubbing alcohol do you remember when you
could this is I guess in the 90s when it
was like came out that you could eat the
paper you could keep the paper on the
piece of Trident and chewed the Trident
do you that guys make it to you that was
yeah that wasn't a thing we did it I
mean you were to Seton paper I told you
adore zine pay they didn't specially
engineer the paper they painted I know
that I'm just saying it was edible you
wasn't gonna kill you you know and I was
a board fat ten-year-old what else are
you gonna do get some [ __ ] paper
Foley your [ __ ] comes out all wrapped up
what about you ever have a hotdog on a
hamburger bun I don't think so but I had
I have had a hotdog on between two
pieces of Wonder Bread and I've done
that I've done that for sure long long
long look in the mirror on that one yeah
we all had those moments we were even
when you're a little kid you were like
ha I don't want to be doing this when
I'm [ __ ] my parents age this is
[ __ ] trash yeah one find a hamburger
on a hotdog bun no I never did I had a
peanut butter and jelly on a hot dog bun
last night that was pretty garbage go to
the store Jesus I don't want to waste
them
what are you doing come on fully you're
embarrassing us um you know what I've
appreciated more as I got older which I
wouldn't touch as a kid is the end of
the like the end of the white bread oh
yeah I hated them as a kid I was like
throw them out get him out of here but
now they got some you know they make it
they make a dense sandwich I'll give you
that yeah I was the same way I wouldn't
need that that was not food to me yeah I
need the bag your dad your dad always
got stuck with that he's the one that he
would have a sandwich with two of them
both any [ __ ] crushing a tuna yeah
yeah that you bought your [ __ ] sucker
I was terrible what about sloppy joes
growing up with your sloppy joe family
little man which around the house dude
Camden hamburger helper or either this
guy is a [ __ ] Kennedy what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] do you think you are no Hamburger
Helper what about TV trays Jeanne off TV
trays yeah what do you mean that's like
just the tray you set up so you can eat
while you're watching yeah yeah it's
still always that's you have one in your
apartment here in Queens
currently to this day we have to be
watching I can't start eating and tell
there's something on the top absolutely
yeah I'm not talking to you what are you
nuts
but ya know we were the whole family
would have them lined right up so that's
when you guys would eat when you guys
would normally where would you eat like
where would you have most of your family
dinners growing up in the kitchen dining
room or in front of the TV always in
front of the TV we're very early on we
ate as a family I remember like when I
was really young
but to last like age 12 through
currently it's always in front of the TV
really brother holiday would be at the
table but that was it yeah you guys
aren't animals you know what I mean do
something well we used to put the TV and
we did we had a TV in the kitchen that
we would sit there and watch TV while we
aim at the table bowling turn the TV off
and talk to somebody in your [ __ ]
family Jesus Christ all right what about
is your mom ever cut your hair no did
you ever cut your mom's hair I was young
I was like eight and it's for always
forgiving after 12 you're good never
have to call nine-one-one and a family
member on a family member no I've called
number one but not on a family member no
and did you have a family member living
in your house when you were growing up
like some not in the nuclear yeah until
they got back on their feet or something
no nobody living in the attic or the
basement or anything for a little while
downstairs no what about a friend from
high school or anything like that do you
ever have a friend stay with you for a
little while why his parents work things
out yes we did have that once and I
think it might be my senior year Chris
gay was his name and he stayed and I
remember the first day he was there he
was boiling pasta or mac and cheese and
he was taking spring water out of the
fridge to use it to boil and I was like
you got do you think a guy down on his
luck would appreciate a little tap talk
about overstepping the line yeah yeah we
had that too one of my brother's friends
his parents were going through something
and just one day his mom pulled up with
him and like him and my mom you know
when the parents like go aside and
they're talking to each other like
whispering you know like this ain't good
got that what he was there for the rest
of the school year it was [ __ ] great
it was like having a new brother for a
little while ya know but the weird thing
was I volunteered it without telling my
parents and then showed up I was like oh
here's the thing up on the spring water
mock
yeah I got one do any male members in
your family have a ponytail no no that
would be a tough one also do any males
in your family wear Stetson or Brut
cologne not that I know I know Drakkar
Noir was like huge no I don't think so
oh man I got my stepdad I just found a
bottle of Stetson man that stuff smells
like cowboys and Winston cigarettes dude
that [ __ ] is no joke little English
leather family what about shaving do you
have an electric razor to use a regular
sheesh all electric first of all I never
shaved clean cuz I got a weak jawline
and bad teeth and a small dick so I
gotta have fun o'clock shadow at all
times but no one ever taught me how to
shave I've never shaved my face with the
razor ever and what's your dad shave
with did he have because the trashy
thing is those Morocco's that have the
three little circles this yeah those are
no good yeah no I always had a handheld
razor old schedule that thing yeah I'm
stuck I'm just like you I can't I hate
shaving my face all the way down unless
I have to because one like when it grows
back at like [ __ ] hurts like breaking
through the skin and then I always like
break out and stuff like that but our
dad's those guys were getting up and
shaving like that every freaking day to
go to work I do that what's this my dad
always had like [ __ ] little pieces of
toilet paper all over his face when he
came downstairs back when men were men
you know what I mean huh hundred percent
I could still hear that sound of like
that happening on the sink yeah I love
it I got a few more here have you ever
run out onto the field during any type
of sporting event yes
high school football I did it and then
the year after I was obsessed with high
school football and the year after my
senior year I still go into the high
school football game I went I started my
god we were playing Marshfield High who
was like undefeated like three years in
a row this juggernaut we're gonna beat
him so I started going around and
telling all the kids that I knew still
they were juniors when I was a senior I
was like you got to take the field I
knew that I couldn't participate but I
started going around the fourth grade I
was like ever do you have to take the
field we were at their high school and
Joe you were that guy home oh dude I was
that guy I was he's painted the whole
like in david putty over here I was way
into it that's tough
wow that's hardcore have you ever yelled
Baba Booey in public no I was never a
stern guy okay no no I hate that [ __ ]
gotcha dude do you remember the last
time your credit card was declined
somewhere I mean it's been a while but
oh yeah yeah it happened all the time
there was a lot of moments where I would
always call my mother and be like hey my
credit card she's like okay thank you
mom what's going on with the [ __ ]
debit card man I had won my most
embarrassing once the only thing I ever
told you I was in a McDonald's
drive-through so I got to the window to
pay God but then that was to close up on
the guy in front of me so I couldn't
even pull out a line I had to wait in
line until I got up to the next window
and I'm like now I'm good what do you do
buying [ __ ] McDonald's with a credit
card
that's [ __ ] garbage Jesus Christ hey
you know got anything liquid for a
[ __ ] quarter pounder it's all tied up
in Bitcoin Joey you a fast-food guy I
haven't been much the last year since
I've been dealing a reflux issue but I
was a huge fast off we were we were all
fast oh yeah well here's your favorite
one well we had a Burger King in my town
so growing up it was all Burger King and
McDonald's it'd be a treat cuz it was
like four miles away or whatever but
networking is now my least favorite
Wendy's is probably number one yeah
McDonald's when it's good is the best
food ever nothing tastes like it yeah
like the burger is salted like good good
McDonald's is as good as it gets but
Wendy
Wendy's to me is the most consistent
Wendy's is like right behind Shake Shack
as far as I'm concerned yeah it's it's
Shake Shack to me is my favorite cheese
burger I've ever had including like I've
been to like high-end [ __ ] you know
the Ritz count cheese shortest Shake
Shack is number one for me the staff the
grease I love it do you have a specific
one in the city you go to the Madison
Square Park yeah yeah that's glassy out
there that's great you sit down you got
the [ __ ] city around you that's clean
living that's attractive people over
there [ __ ] enjoying themselves this
might be garbage but I got married in
City Hall and walked to that Shake Shack
adage I get married in City Hall to that
is that yeah and then we went to Shake
Shack
this is the best Sara my wife went back
to work and finished her shift she
didn't come to shake [ __ ] we ended up
having like a wedding you see a nurse or
something what's going open we ended up
having a wet like we had a big wedding
with all our yeah but the day we
actually got married in the courthouse
she went back to work like later in the
afternoon oh that's like World War two
[ __ ] I just got to get back on the
assembly line that accident no one's
gonna make these b-52s on their own
let's I got howitzer shells to make what
do you got I just got one more I think I
just got yeah I just got one more to
have I know you're pretty anxious guy as
as am I and I think Foley is well when
was the last time or would you ever send
anything back why would you ever send
anything back at a restaurant well I'm
not that kind of guy I don't have that I
recently yesterday I do a thing I get a
bagel at lots of bagels in a story a
bets big overhead I go every morning and
I like it soft and if they give me one
that's like dark brown and kind of burnt
I'll go you know what I'm gonna get two
bagels today I won't say can I get that
one instead yeah I can't order too I'll
I'll just order a second meal a lot of
time oh you know what I changed my mind
I'll take this
but I also want that what's out what I
really want Wow
just think how great the world would be
if everybody had that mentality like I'm
right there with you like I'm not a
perfect guy but if something like comes
out like slightly wrong at a restaurant
like not like completely the opposite of
what I ordered
I'm just [ __ ] eating it I'm not
saying anything yeah dude you could give
me the wrong dish I could order chicken
arm you can send me out you know a
[ __ ] steak and I'm like well this is
what I'm having now and just keep my
head down and shut the [ __ ] up yeah when
you when you see people treating people
like that [ __ ] like garbage you're
like you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] when
that whole popeyes chicken sandwich
craze was going around I'll admit I got
caught up in it
I am zero in the middle I understood I
wanted to check it out and like this the
Popeyes on 21st Street in Queens was
packed this [ __ ] lady walks up to the
front and goes and this is she's a cure
she had she goes are those fries fresh I
want fresh fries I mean she wanted to
taste the fries to see if they were
fresh a [ __ ] sample and a Popeye's
they probably are yeah they're and
they're living their best life yeah all
right my final question to you mr. Joe
list here on are you garbage is have you
ever been involved or any member of your
family ever been involved with any type
of parade oh yeah my he's charged in
high school football games he's probably
the [ __ ] huge
well my uncle is like was a fireman so
they're always there the fire truck guy
I've been on a fire truck for a parade
throwing candy out yes I've been that
guy high school football jacket on that
head this is probably pretty high school
for me but yeah my own it was a big deal
when my uncle drove the firetruck in the
parade that was like a we gotta get
there early get a spot uncle Doug is
driving the fire truck there's something
on you mental something I always thought
was trashy even when I was a little kid
with those Shriners guys that drove
around in those little cars during
parades yeah
what the [ __ ] are these guys deal
Blackey hats on - they did they had like
that they had like the Casablanca hats
on and I always wonder like do they
drive these home have you never you
never see them on the highway or come in
a tiny garage good [ __ ] Joe list Barban
hundred percent garbage the football
thing man my face and I would run along
the sideline with the line of scrimmage
like every time they moved I would run
to the line of scrimmage so we had a big
run I would go bomb and down the side
way and that went from age 8 all the way
up through senior year after you
graduated high school you would you
would go to these games you were doing
this
oh yeah big-time college I mean after
high school I was doing like one open
mic a week to open mikes a week that was
like my life so Friday night I wanna get
you sorry go I'm sorry guy kippy I would
you said I could picture the seniors
like I said Josie er yeah he's gonna
make us run [ __ ] jelly can't I sprained
my ankle last week why didn't she get
involved in the team start coaching or
something like that I was but to me as a
lover of sports it was like a five
dollar game live right that's true
gotcha game is a good time it is a good
time
oh yeah I got football on Friday and
then Saturday I'd watch college all day
and then Sunday I'd watch the [ __ ]
Pats kid okay you go yeah how do you
feel about your buddy Tom Brady going
down to Florida you know what's weird is
that like because of the Panda all like
[ __ ] I'm like I hesitated like I guess
but I've been saying for a while I'm
excited to have a new new guy let's see
what the new guy can do it was 20 years
so do you think there's a chance that
they will try to finagle Trevor Lawrence
or Joe burrows I don't think for what
I've heard I got a couple insider
information they're really high on
stellar stood out on I say his name yeah
why are you talking about
yeah jarett's did well or both of those
kids are gonna be really good though Jim
burrows or Trevor Lawrence they're gonna
be awesome NFL quarterbacks I think oh
yeah I also I was a Ryan Leaf over
Peyton Manning guy so really yeah my two
great sports things were I was on record
saying Keith van Horn was gonna be a
hall-of-famer and Ryan those are my two
great sport predictions of all time from
the next you're talking about being well
yeah but like before when he was drafted
coming out I was like this guy's all
good when the Mets had that run and
[ __ ] Jersey fans were like awed and
that's a [ __ ] stink that was my that
was my question I forgot were you a
frequent sports radio caller that's
[ __ ] that's a tough one I mean also
too if you're charging the field at a
high school football game you're
definitely calling the radio station
that's not the craziest thing no yeah I
love one of my favorite scenes in a
movie is the documentary comedian where
Seinfeld's talking about going to Long
Island and he goes it's everything
you've tried not to be but you know deep
down still are that happy with
everything you hate looking back at ya
every time I go back to Philly it's the
same thing I'm like you guys are [ __ ]
you're all animals and I don't want to
be anything like you yeah I feel that
way and I watch the Pats and Brady
throws a pic and I'm like you [ __ ] of
course
have you ever added the phrase first
time long time no I've never done that
no well Joe thank you so much man I am
this was great we appreciate you sit one
of this you got a new podcast I'll
called mindful metal jacket with Joe
list yeah
anything else you want the gang to know
that I'm sure they probably already know
but yeah Tuesdays with stories on
Tuesday Michael middle jacket on
Thursday and that is our only source of
income or artistic freedom man sometimes
yeah so yeah check those out and thanks
for having me guys it was really fun
buddy thank you so much we really
appreciate you coming on
you got anything just you know rate rate
review subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube you can subscribe
and comment there as well we appreciate
it guys at kevin ryan comedy on all
social media thanks
yep guys thank you very much for tuning
in this has been are you garbage and
we'll see you guys next time thank you
thanks guys thanks